[Music]
hey everybody we got new flash to
breakdown flash versus Nora with a whole
bunch more Easter eggs and clues about
what's happening in the future in
another crossover teaser for the monitor
character if you're not a big comic book
person I'll explain him at the end of
the video we'll talk about Flash stuff
first there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
flash related comment on the video
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet but number 10 we
start with the flash back to explain how
spin got her powers it's actually her
phone that got the powers not her so
they're doing something different this
season where they used that dark matter
satellite that the thinker created to
create organic meta technology the
episode did a pretty good job of
explaining how that works it looks just
like Borg technology it's a mixture of
organic and artificial parts so this
season you'll have a mixture of
technological metas like Captain Cold
who uses a gun to give him his powers or
someone like King shark who has
biologically-based powers 9 the baseball
game they have a couple funny moments
but there really isn't much of a
baseball game because the person comes
charging onto the set and they give you
the intro to how spins powers working
how she controls people using her phone
and those screens they also set up that
funny storyline where Nora spent most of
the episode shading iris it got a little
cringy at times but I think they were
just trying to build the tension between
them till it came to a head at the end
of the episode so it just forced a
confrontation between the two of them
she was ripping into iris so hard though
and I know a lot of you probably felt
like she was super gullible with the
meta I think there's a reason for that
that I'll explain in a second but if
you're not a big comic book reader I've
talked a little bit about spins powers
in the comics it's actually a
combination of two different Metis the
characters spin is a media mogul that
has a network of TV stations radio
stations he uses a meta that he chains
up to make people's fears come true the
way the TV show used that was more like
straight-up mind control ate Nora learns
how to create windmills like Barry at
the fire only it's iris that has to help
him because Barry gets emceed and runs
off to Las Vegas it's a bonding moment
for them but it's just another episode
where Nora
learns a new ability just expect her to
start unlocking cooler abilities the
longer she's on the TV show 7 Nora is a
terrible spy so she tries to go to get
information on spin they use it for more
of a funny moment but if it seemed like
Nora was super gullible and not willing
to believe that spin could possibly be a
bad person it's probably just to set up
a bigger twist later on because remember
Sherlock wells said somebody else in the
future gave Nora the idea to come back
in the past and change history Nora has
not said who that is yet but again at
the end of this week's episode we also
get the details from her that it was
someone else that helped her find out
that she had flash powers it wasn't iris
because she'd been dampening them the
whole time so just more clues about a
mystery person in the future
that's manipulating Nora so that's why
during the episode they wanted to make
it seem like Nora was born yesterday so
that it's more believable that someone
could do that to her in the future but
number 6
Caitlin punches Sherlock well this was
just a really quick funny moment in more
foreshadowing for her killer frost
storyline they just want to get you to
see Caitlin reacting in anger so those
are usually the times when killer frost
would manifest most of that seems like
it'll happen with her father's story arc
I think he's showing up either in next
week's episode or the week after that
sometime really really soon so anytime
she's in a really extreme emotional
state that's usually when killer frost
stuff happens so you can just imagine if
she's like this now what it's gonna be
like when she reunites with her father
number 5 the big stadium battle
obviously a big callback to
reverse-flash vs flash during season 1
episode 9 it was a great episode
but obviously they're playing it with a
few twists this time so number 4 when
they're flying at each other remember
that really iconic moment from season 1
they do that exact same shot only this
time it's reversed because Nora has the
ability to rewind time just a little bit
so this time because of her ability it
looks like Barry's running backwards at
her while she's running forwards to him
and then she uses another signature
reverse flash move to almost try and
kill him by vibrating her hand through
his chest I think I said it in my last
trailer video but I do think that it's
good chance that you barred Thawne is
the person pretending to be Nora's
friend in the future
trying to
helped her discover her powers and then
giving her the idea quote-unquote to go
back and change history because what's
the worst thing that could possibly
happen three they learned cicadas true
origin and how his powers work it's all
part of that satellite that the thinker
juiced up with dark matter when Nora
came back to destroy it with Barry it
changed his original trajectory and it
looks like cicada was hit with shrapnel
and that's what the scar is from in his
chest and then you see like the
latticework underneath with all the
weird metahuman veins it's just like the
back of spins phone so number two this
is probably an even bigger deal they
create a bunch of organic technology
using this twist so think of it in a
more Star Trek way Borg satellite
infests everything with a bunch of
nanoprobes so some stuff is gonna be
turned into special metahuman tech that
we'll find out about and we'll create
new metas then we'll probably have some
old classics like next week's meta is
going to be a rag doll from the comics
it'll be interesting to see how they
explain his powers if it's related to
the satellite or if they're just gonna
go with the comic book explainer because
he's basically triple-jointed he had a
special operation to make him like that
biggest one of course number one they
reveal why Nora hates iris so much
because she was dampening her powers her
entire life up to about six months ago
surprise surprise mystery person in the
future helps her discover she has powers
and sent her off on this path that would
create the situation that they're in
right now so the way they're playing it
is they're just trying to drive a wedge
between the flash families so it leaves
Nora a little more vulnerable because
remember she's super gullible like she
was just totally willing to believe this
spin was an awesome person so obviously
that's gonna go terrible for them but
let me know in the comments what do you
think is going on with this mystery
person in the future that one helped
Nora realize she had powers and then
give her the idea to go back into the
past because apparently she will believe
anything that anybody tells her all you
would have to do is pretend to be her
friend and I'm just hoping that it's
gonna be somebody who works at the flash
Museum who just happens to secretly be a
version of eobard thawne but because we
just found out the zoom is coming back
during the hundredth episode with other
evil speedsters hopefully that's the
episode where they give us the answer to
that question in addition to just being
a whole bunch of fanservice because all
those speedsters are coming back but if
you didn't see it they were
field the first look at the monitor from
the crossover episode it's gonna be
crazy he is right off the comic book
page so important thing here though is
the book that he is holding in this
picture is the same book of weird speed
force symbols that Superman is reading
from in his black costume there whatever
it is it seems like it's going to be
critical to all this reality warping and
destiny changing the reason why we see
Barry in the green arrow costume and
Oliver wearing Barry's flash costume I
think they're almost done filming a lot
of that so we'll probably get a trailer
for that in the next couple of weeks but
post all your monitor ante monitor
theories in the comments below I feel
like we might get a teaser for him but
he's such a big character that they
might just introduce the concept of the
monitors then maybe save anti-monitor
for a post-credits scene because it just
feels too soon to do him if you're not
going to go straight to crisis on
Infinite Earths in your next crossover
and I don't think that that's gonna
happen for a couple more years I'll post
my new flash trailer video tomorrow
morning
they just confirmed that they're gonna
do a Winter Soldier TV show with
Sebastian Stan and Anthony Mackey's
Falcon character on the Disney streaming
service so I'll do a video for that
tomorrow too
can you see them no Disney is coming for
your money big time they want to force
you to have to pay for this new
streaming service like you want to get
all this hot Avengers content you're
gonna have to pay for it so we can freak
out about that tomorrow
I'll name giveaway winners when I post
those click here to watch Tom Holland
talk about the 3rd spider-man film after
spider-man far from home and click here
to learn about the brand new cast member
and click here for that zoom teaser for
the hundredth episode thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]